[Music]
we'd love to watching our favorite
Disney Princesses and we were kids but
they might not have been the best role
models stay tuned until the end to know
what went wrong in the movie frozen if
you love Disney movies as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten terrible lessons
Disney movies shouldn't be teaching kids
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs what
should you do if your daughter was more
beautiful than you you would simply wait
until the teenager gets a few simples
and a weird new style during her awkward
phase not try to kill her and ask a
hunter to come back with her heart we
understand that the young princess had
no other choice but to run away into the
forest and find someplace to be safe but
why does keep in a house the only thing
that she has to offer to the dwarfs why
is she leaving a life of slavery to do
the same thing for strangers Disney
wanted to show that she was getting
ready to be a good housewife for a
future husband but we hope that men
would be looking for much more than that
like a sandwich
no we're kidding Snow White never learns
that she should never trust strangers
because she didn't mind biting an apple
offered by an old witch we have to admit
that we would have done the same thing
in Girl Scouts for at our door but this
time she decided to trust an ugly and
evil witch and by the way why can't the
Evil Queen pretend to be a Girl Scout
instead if you want to teach kids how to
be evil give them better ideas Disney
and what about the happy ending a
stranger decided to kiss her dead body
we don't know about you but this first
impression wouldn't encourage us to
marry this man Cinderella this
rags-to-riches story is probably the
most popular fairy tale and also the
weirdest one Cinderella was treated like
a servant by her evil stepmother and her
stepsisters it would be too easy to say
that she should have asked for help it's
very hard to leave everything behind
when you've been told for years that you
deserved it but when you think about it
her happily ever after isn't really
happy either Cinderella didn't help
herself
or ask for help she just waited for a
fairy godmother to magically
and save her if you're waiting for that
you'll be waiting for a long time kid
then she went to a ball where she met a
prince who was looking for a woman to
marry if you ever go to a party where a
rich player is just looking for a new
girlfriend you should never think that
he is husband material
then he spends all the evening dancing
with her without even asking what her
name was the only thing that mattered to
him was that she was pretty and
grown-ups would understand that dancing
was a symbol for getting luckier than
this anyway Cinderella had to leave at
midnight
leaving one shoe behind when looking for
her the prince couldn't even remember
what she looked like he simply asked
every girl in the kingdom to try on the
shoe to see if it fits you deserve
better than this girl Sleeping Beauty we
retired of Disney Princesses who only
knew how to be pretty and clean the
house this is why Disney made sure that
we would get a Disney princess who only
knows how to be pretty the first things
the fairies thought about were the gift
of beauty and the gift of the song they
just didn't have time to give her the
gift of the good housewife before
Maleficent ruined the party the young
princess was singing alone in the woods
when she first met her friends we don't
know about you but we wouldn't be
enchanted to meet a stranger who
randomly starts singing and dancing with
us or at least we wouldn't start crying
when the fairies would tell us that we
can't be with him or maybe that's
because that's when the fairies finally
told her that she was stuck in an
arranged marriage her name was actually
Aurora and her parents had been waiting
for her during all this time she didn't
know about that for 16 years and her
parents suddenly wanted her to get
married and make babies she was just
tired of this and it wasn't that bad to
sleep for a couple of months and how she
was ready to face this but she never
thought that she would be ready to face
a stranger randomly kissing her while
she was sleeping Disney should teach
kids that if she can't say no she can't
say yes The Little Mermaid Ariel never
liked to follow the rules she was
obsessed with the human world even
though her father thought that she
shouldn't be interested in that she was
just a normal teenager after all but it
got worse when she met a prince and
immediately fell in love with him even
though they never even had the chance to
talk she was ready to leave everything
behind for this stranger her world her
family and even her own identity this is
why she made a deal with the witch to
have a pair of legs in exchange for her
voice and she only had three
days to make the stranger fall in love
with her or she would have to suffer a
terrible fate we don't know about you
but we think that you should never
change who you are to please your crush
mostly when you don't even know them
this is how you give away the best
things you had the reasons why he would
have loved you and isn't it a terrible
idea to not be able to communicate in
any way just because you want to look
better for once the prince was decent
enough not to want to kiss a girl
without her consent Arielle got
everything wrong and she is just
extremely lucky that she got the chance
to live a happy ending it didn't end
that way in the original fairy tale
Beauty and the Beast
we thought that we would finally have
the chance to meet a good role model
when we saw that Belle was really smart
she wasn't interested in gaston and the
only man that she loved was her father
however she loved him a little too much
and everything turned out to be wrong
when she tried to save her father she
asked the Beast to take her as his
prisoner and let her father be free in
exchange what was a really courageous
decision but it didn't take too much
time before everything turned out to be
wrong just like many other women she
made the mistake to think that she could
turn a bad man into a Prince Charming we
understand that she had no other choice
but to accept this situation because she
couldn't escape but she became a
terrible role model when she actually
fell in love with him okay he did have a
big library but you should know that
it's not only the size that matters she
should have run away as soon as she had
the opportunity to do so but she
eventually came back because she
realized that she loved the man who
kidnapped her this shouldn't be called a
love story this should be called the
Stockholm Syndrome sorry Emma Watson but
you didn't manage to turn it into a
feminist story in the live-action movie
Aladdin let's travel to another country
to see if things are better down there
this time we followed the story of a
young thief he actually had a good
reason to be a fee so that's okay but
giving bread to poor kids doesn't make
you a perfect person the problem was
that he was interested in Princess
Jasmine even though he knew nothing
about her once again it was
based on looks and this time the street
urchin thought wealth and status would
make people like him it actually worked
for most people but not Princess Jasmine
this is why he had to find another way
to make her fall in love with him and he
just kept lying lying and lying during
the whole story even my two genie when
he broke his promise to lemon out of the
lamp this is not the kind of people that
you should trust this is why Jasmine
told him that she wasn't a prize to be
won for shortly after she agreed to fly
away with him on his magic carpet and if
it's not a good idea to follow a
stranger in its car it's not a good idea
to fly around the world with him a few
hundred feet above the ground Aladdin
did learn his lesson at the end but no
matter what many kids were convinced
that you could lie as long as you make
sure that everyone forgives you after
the Princess and the Frog with a more
recent story we hope that Disney would
make the opportunity to make something
better we finally met a young woman who
had ambitions and worked hard to start
her own restaurant but surprisingly many
people loved Charlotte even more so we
guess that kids are not interested in
better role models anyway Tiana wanted
to start her own restaurant and she was
ready to do anything for this including
kissing a frog what is she going to do
next when a man asks her for a special
service exchange for money
don't encourage young girls to do one of
the oldest jobs in the world
however he learned at the end of the
movie that Marion's the money is totally
fine if you're a guy
we won't thank Disney for teaching us
that many people also criticize that
Disney wasn't really ready for their
first broad princess because she was
actually dreamed for most of the movie
Lulu was also shown in a stereotypical
way which isn't good for people who
practice this religion in the end Tiana
was almost ready to give up everything
just to be with Naveen why does easily
create such an ambitious character just
to ruin everything at the end well she
did get the guy and the restaurant at
the end but we should stop telling girls
that they will be lucky if they take the
easy way brave and here comes a Disney
princess who is not interested in a
prince unfortunately that doesn't make
the movie perfect that's because her
parents still thought that getting
married was one of the most important
things ever and traditions couldn't be
broken they thought that that was the
only way their daughter could be happy
and
she decided to compete for her own hand
pretending to be someone you're not
won't make you happy either and
thankfully Merida agreed to this
unfortunately it was sad to see that she
felt like she didn't belong in her
family either this Disney movie showed
that being the oldest sucks girls never
get along with their mothers and little
boys always get away with everything
while a lot of people can relate to this
that shouldn't be a role model but what
is it girls supposed to do we were shown
that being strong was only for boys
being a lady means that you can't have
fun and all men are good in sports if
there is one thing you could do it's
simply to run away from your problems
thankfully Merida was there to break the
rules but that shouldn't include things
like becoming friends with a bear or
taking food for strangers while brave
was an improvement we can't say that
Disney became an a-plus for this lesson
tangled we couldn't wait to see this new
Disney Princess but then we were really
disappointed right at the beginning of
the story
that's because Flynn Rider was the one
who narrated Rapunzel's story as if she
didn't have a work to say about that
maybe they think that she's not capable
of handling her own life that seemed to
be the case in the original fairy tale
because the princess never used her own
hair to escape but they explained that
she was scared of the outside world in
the movie so it made more sense and we
were happy to see that she was terrified
to see a man break into her room and she
even fought back she used a pan a symbol
of a woman who stays at home against him
come on girl don't leave with him right
after why does she need a man to save
her like all the other Disney Princesses
before her at least if there was one
good thing about this movie it is that
she had to save him too however the only
way to save Rapunzel was to cut her hair
it was a tragic moment and she seemed to
lose her youth and her from the
when her hair turns short and brown but
she is much more than her hair we also
don't like that a princess can only live
happily ever after if she gets married
this isn't only about boys frozen and
here come the Disney Princesses or the
princess and the Queen who were finally
better role models not once again we
can't say that they are perfect one of
the biggest mistakes that Elsa ever did
was to simply run away from her problems
that's a normal reaction for a young kid
but even when she was the queen she just
left her Kingdom to lock herself in her
ice castle and leave everyone suffering
in an eternal winter it is not until the
end of the movie that she finally faces
this problem and how come she can't talk
to her sister about this even when they
are grownups let's talk about onna -
once again a Disney princess fell in
love with a stranger and immediately
wanted to marry him this was when Elsa
said one of the best things ever you
can't marry a man you just met every
other character on this list will have
to learn something from this but we have
to admit that she fell in love with
Kristoff a little too fast - but that's
still better than what we've seen
previously and by the way we don't even
know how she didn't die from hypothermia
Disney animators clearly don't know
anything about winter witch terrible
lesson did you learn from Disney movies
don't be shy to answer in the comments
section down below we'd love to hear
what you think and that's it for 10
terrible lessons Disney movies shouldn't
be teaching kids if you liked this video
don't forget to subscribe and please
give us a big thumbs up thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]